Speaker 1: We are hearing from people
via discord. You can join at David
Pakman dot com slash discord.
Let's go let's go a little bit
international. Let's go to Damián from
Switzerland. Damian, you're on the air.
Hi, David. Can you hear me? I can hear you.
Speaker 2: Perfect, thank you. So first of all,
I love watching you. I'm very interested in
your politics. And my question for you is,
as I have traveled many times to the U.S. and I
have talked to a lot of people in rural areas,
and what I never understood is like I saw, like
the infrastructure is crumbling and they don't
have access to good health care and the school
system is bad. But when I was talking to people,
like their main concern was, oh, the president
has to be against abortion or for socialism or
Kansler culture is like the biggest issue. Yeah.
Even though they they maybe have bad teeth or
can't afford health care. And my question is just
like that's something I've never understood or
how can you change or convince these people
that maybe the socialism that actually is a
social welfare state is actually not too bad?
Speaker 1: Yeah. You know, I also used to not
understand how how could it be how could how do
people get to be like this? And then I spent some
time in rural northern Indiana and spending time
there actually made me understand how it happens.
Because when you are in these rural places with
first of all, everybody around you is is almost
identical to you in terms of their profile.
It's basically people that are there the
same race as you. They're the same religion.
They're the same culturally. They're all born
right there in Indiana. You start with that and
all you have are shooting ranges, rodeos and
churches. That's all you have. And so you go to
church and it's these mega churches and everybody
sits there and the pastor tells everybody the same
thing. And it's about abortion and it's about this
and that and the other thing. And so I understood
well, like, of course, if you grow up like that,
this is this this is the world view you're going
to end up with unless you're really motivated
to look around at other ways that that people
live. So I think understanding that is a really
important first step and even hoping to try
to change some of these folks points of view.
Speaker 2: So it definitely is a big cultural
difference. Oh, yeah, the rural areas and cities
and I think yeah, I mean I mean, maybe if they
see, for example, if Biden or the Democrats,
if they get Bilston, that people have
more access to health care and stuff,
maybe they see like, oh, it's actually not too
bad that socialism like what they think that is.
Speaker 1: I mean, it's not the other issue is
what they think is socialism is not actually
socialism. That's a whole other story.
Speaker 2: Yeah, yeah. I mean,
when you compare like Switzerland or Venezuela
or Denmark, that's like completely different
countries. Absolutely. There's a big difference
between social welfare, state and socialism.
Speaker 1: What what part
of Switzerland are you in?
Speaker 2: I mean, like from
the Swiss German speaking part,
like close to serik, like the central area.
Speaker 1: Oh OK, very nice. I've been to Zurich,
one of my favorite cities in the world.
Speaker 2: Oh, yeah. Nice. Nice. Yep. And the
unification was also in Europe the last few days.
Speaker 1: It was. I've been I've been mostly
in Spain and it was beautiful.
Speaker 2: Oh nice. Spain is
also absolutely beautiful. Yeah.
Speaker 1: All right, my friend,
I appreciate the call. Thank you. Yeah,
absolutely. Let's take a very quick break.
If you're holding right now to talk to me, don't
hang up unless you're furious at how long it's
been. But stay on hold because I'm going to take
a few more calls right after this short break